[Música]
gracias buenas tardes qué ganas tenía de
tener público
gracias por venir no sabéis la cantidad
de veces que me muerdo la lengua me
muerdo mucho la lengua trabajo en radio
trabajo en televisión quizá no debería
decir esto públicamente pero me muerdo y
me mordido muchas muchas veces la lengua
de eso quiero hablaros en la tarde de
hoy quiero hablaros una cosa que se
llama conformidad veréis la conformidad
luego luego hablaremos en el tema pero
ya os adelanto que al menos una cuarta
parte de los que estáis aquí al menos
una cuarta parte estaría dispuesto a
cambiar de opinión debido a la presión
del grupo debido a la presión de los
demás
esta es la conformidad y de esto llevo
dándole vueltas de un tiempo a esta
parte desde la moción de censura hacia
aquí llevo llevado de vuelta a una cosa
que tiene que ver con mi profesión con
con la exposición pública está en la
radio en la tele y estar expuesto
delante de todos tienen algunas cosas
tiene muchas cosas divertidas son todo
como las cuentas pasado el tiempo voy a
contar una historia una cuna extra que
ahora es divertida como me pasó no tanto
recordó que fue la noche del golpe de
estado' turquía nos pilló en directo un
programa trepidante en la tele cinco
horas de programa de directo en el que
contamos técnicamente todo lo que había
contar que parecía que estaba empezando
un golpe de estado en turquía que el
golpe de estado se consolidaba que el
presidente recep tayeb erdogán entrar a
través de una conexión en facetime que
imagino que recordaréis que se abortaba
de alguna manera a que el golpe de
estado que la gente sale a la calle que
había ráfagas de tiros del ejército
sobre el bósforo todos lo contamos en
directo y contamos que el golpe de
estado había fracasado técnicamente
desde el punto de vista periodístico
había sido un muy buen programa pero
en estas ocasiones tan especiales muchos
compañeros de profesión se prestan
voluntarios a ofrecerte información y
hubo uno concretamente que recordó que
me mandó un guasave me dijo y hay una
delegación de españoles allí en estambul
no te quieres el teléfono por supuesto
pásame lo me pasó el teléfono sólo día
producción a producción le dije llamas
inmediatamente aseguraos de que están en
estambul ahora vamos a meter la pata
llamado me dijeron todo que están allí
no tienes el teléfono les saludo me
contesta hacemos una entrevista en
directo estupenda y todo sale fenomenal
guau
me vuelve a llamar a mandar un mensaje y
también tengo el teléfono de un experto
en política internacional pasa en el
teléfono directamente le pasó el
teléfono a producción ya sin la
precaución de que comprobaran que estaba
en estambul me dice no tienes al
teléfono todo ok me vengo arriba porque
el otro haya salido bien y digo si usted
mira por la ventana que ve y me dice la
cibeles estoy madrid
ese tipo de cosas cuando estás expuesto
tienen especial gravedad porque todo el
mundo el fallo saber lo que pasó después
no hubo alud de críticas y lo entiendes
porque es un fallo que no trata de
evitar pero a veces estas cosas pasan os
quiero hablar os quiero preguntar a
vosotros acerca de esto de la crítica
que pasa cuando critican qué os pasa a
vosotros cuando os critican mejor dicho
pues todos cuando os mordéis la lengua
decir lo que pensáis de verdad decir lo
que pensáis o decís aquello que sabéis
que tenéis que decir para volar porque
mola volar
a esto he estado dando muchas vueltas
últimamente hay una frase que yo
escuchaba últimamente muy a menudo y
seguro que os suena un bar con amigos
una cafetería un debate animado y
alguien dice a ver que esto que estoy
diciendo aquí jamás lo diría en las
redes
y porque aquí tienes miedo
porque técnicamente una opinión cuando
uno la emite sabe perfectamente que no
va a gustar a todo el mundo no puede
gustar a todo el mundo siguió dándole
vueltas a esto y voy porque es sergio
porque te muerde la lengua porque no
dice lo que quiere es decir porque no
dices lo que piensas tienes miedo de lo
que piensas te avergüenzas de lo que
piensas que pasa otra pregunta cuál de
esas líneas la alabe o la cee tiene el
mismo tamaño que la vertical que veis a
la izquierda no respondáis salamón solo
monas en el año 1951 demostró que al
menos la cuarta parte de los que estáis
aquí diría que la respuesta correcta es
la a olave cuando a todas luces enlace
si antes habéis escuchado la opinión de
los demás esto ocurría en el mundo
offline con nueve tíos y uno como objeto
de estudio
qué crees que ocurriría hoy con las
redes sociales ante un mundo potencial
qué opina sobre lo que vosotros decís de
esas rayitas
esto lo que yo me he preguntado porque
esto lo que yo sufridos voy a contar el
día que me caí en la marmita de pequeño
ese día mi bebito a la pócima 6 de
diciembre de 2014
esa noche hice una entevista muy
polémica y el 20 por ciento es la
gráfica
la noche de 6 a 7 de diciembre el 20% de
todas las menciones que he tenido en mi
cuenta de twitter en mis 9 años de
vigencia de la cuenta el 20 por ciento
tuvieron lugar en diciembre de 2014 y de
ese 20% más del 80% tuvieron lugar en
esa noche 21 mil menciones de las 106
mil que tenido a lo largo de toda mi
vida no me interesa la verdad voy a
analizar el contenido de la entrevista a
la gente le podría gustar como
entrevistó le puede gustar más una
pregunta a otra no no es relevante pero
sí me interesa fijaos qué datos 10.409
menciones en 24 horas 6.700 en 12 599 en
una hora dos tweets por cada diez
segundos y no todos eran buenos o no de
hecho ninguno era bueno
como queráis que esto puede afectarte a
cualquiera de vosotros
es complicado fijaos
yo me hacía fotos cuando era joven
ingenuo sigo siendo joven nos exige no
hacía fotos con los líderes de todos los
partidos políticos porque quería tenía
un objetivo que era intentar acercar la
política a la calle a la gente y decir a
la gente se puede hablar de esto de
manera desenfadada no pasa nada entonces
yo me hacía selfish porque soy el rey
del self y con lync era republicana
alicia sánchez camacho de partido
popular
el secretario general del psoe entonces
de sangre el servicio me llevaba al
curro el palo self y durán y lleida que
alucinaba con el presidente del gobierno
entonces
y con el líder de la oposición entonces
por citó a los entreviste después en el
palacio de la moncloa
hasta que un día
hasta que un día y de esto no me dado
cuenta hasta ahora preparando esta
charla de hoy hasta aquí un día
en un medio
después de las muchas críticas que yo
había soportado hubo una chica lo
dijeron no recuerdo exactamente con qué
foto de qué personaje político pero sí
de qué partido político dijeron fíjate
cómo se hace fotos con los suyos con qué
impunidad esta es la foto de sergio
martín y entonces yo hice algo que
seguramente vosotros hacéis en vuestra
vida cotidiana todos los días qué es
no quiero problemas
podría decir lo que pienso podría dar la
batalla podría pero por ejemplo tú o tú
tienes una tienda un negocio un bar para
que vas a decir que es del madrid o del
barça para echarte en contra la mitad de
la posible de la potencial clientela
en el fondo no quiero problemas no
quieres problemas eso seguro que lo
estés pensando y en realidad funcionaría
si no fuera por un pequeño detalle es
que somos seres sociales que necesitamos
pisar la plaza pública necesitamos decir
lo que opinamos de vez en cuando
necesitamos formar parte de esto que se
llama opinión pública
y entonces
y aquí llegan capítulo de las
conclusiones entonces ahora preparando
esta charla estos días resulta que
descubro
y como me haya pasado como le había
pasado a uno de cada dos de cada diez en
el experimento de solomont as yo me
había auto censurado
ya había modificado mi opinión por la
presión del grupo haya pensado que no es
más que lo que había mantenido firme el
fuerte después de haberme caído en la
marmita de pequeño cuando me vi la
próxima pero sin embargo hubo un momento
en el que inconscientemente aquello sí
que caló y yo como el que tiene un
negocio y un día decide no expresar
públicamente su opinión acerca de un
partido de un equipo de fútbol porque
para qué quiere meterse en líos
yo sería inconscientemente decidí dejar
a meterme en líos y ese día decidí dejar
de publicar selfish niños haciendo el
chorra con políticos y no me di cuenta
entonces me doy cuenta ahora y es ahora
cuando yo planteo
mira creo creo de verdad que oh
dices lo que piensas o te atreves a
decir lo que piensas y lo luchas lo
peleas
y asumes el riesgo que supone no molar
para hacer un freak y una social yo que
sé las etiquetas que te pueden poner o
corres el riesgo de decir una cosa y
pensar otra
y creo que este riesgo y ahí está la
clave de lo de las redes sociales y de
la tecnología para ser más humanos
creo que la novedad con respecto al
estudio que ellos presentaba que el del
año 51 es que ahora todo es exponencial
las redes sociales el mundo global el
hecho de que nos puedan escuchar
potencialmente bienes de personas hace
que potencialmente podamos
multiplicar las razones por las que
prefiramos no meternos en líos porque
para que en el fondo que más da una
última conclusión
que es en la que yo estoy ahora todo
esto es un proceso por ciento que
comparto con vosotros este proceso tiene
que ver en mi vida desde que me han
pasado algunas cosas recientemente hasta
ahora
o dices lo que piensas o corres el
riesgo que es mi tesis en la que estoy
ahora mañana
o dices lo que piensas asumes el riesgo
o quizá porque eres un animal social y
necesitas decir lo que piensas ocurre a
un efecto muy sutil que es que tengas
que modificar ligeramente la manera en
la que piensas para poder decir lo que
piensas es un riesgo enorme y yo contra
eso me reveló buenas tardes
[Aplausos]